filmmakers love to throw all kinds of
extra treats into their movies for
égalité fans nicknamed Easter eggs
because the just barely hidden and fun
to find these inside jokes visual gags
and pop-culture references add another
level of enjoyment to the viewing
experience viewers and fans discover
most of them right away but others are a
little too well hidden take these Easter
eggs for example years went by before
anybody noticed them the topless woman
in the rescuers in this 1977 animated
Disney movie the titular mice Bernard
and Bianca take flight on the back of a
bird as they zoom past buildings a still
image of a naked woman appears in a
window in two different non-consecutive
frames
nobody noticed a fraction of a second
worth of nudity placed by a troublemaker
in a post-production house during the
theatrical release and a different print
was used when the rescuers was first
released on VHS when the movie was
re-released on tape in 1999 better VHS
players and their pausing capabilities
led to the Easter eggs discovery the
news spread and Disney recalled three
million videos Frisky Wizards in Harry
Potter and the Prisoner of Azkaban the
end credits of the third Harry Potter
movie involved in rodders map detailing
the comings and goings of all Hogwarts
personnel in the form of footprints
amidst all the steps going to and fro
there's a brief bit in the corner
depicting two pairs of footprints very
close together and facing each other
yep those were a couple of teenage
Wizards making some real magic with each
other it wasn't noticed until 2011 seven
years after the film's theatrical
release Waldo in Apocalypto Mel Gibson's
directorial follow-up to the Passion of
the Christ was 2006 s Apocalypto a
violent drama about the fall of the
Mayan Empire one of the most striking
and haunting images of the film is a
mass grave of fallen Mayans for some
reason Gibson inserted a single frame of
an actor dressed as Waldo as in Where's
Waldo the Easter egg was a
only present in the theatrical release
of the movie and not the home video
version which meant this bizarre extra
wasn't discovered until bootlegs of the
original cut surface Jack Skellington in
beetlejuice
in Tim Burton's beetlejuice there's a
scene in which the ghost with the most
rises out of the town model his head
spinning pay attention and you'll see a
creepy little skull on the top of his
head we obviously had no way of knowing
at the time but that skull was the
prototype for Jack Skellington the main
character in Tim Burton's stop-motion
animated movie The Nightmare Before
Christmas released five years after
beetlejuice
thanks for watching subscribe to our
YouTube channel to watch more videos
like the one you just saw and leave us a
comment to let us know what Easter Egg
you've spotted that no one else has